it's candidate along with Reason
magazine editor-in-chief Matt Welch and
recent calm and recent TV
editor-in-chief Nicholas P also known as
dr. G morning ladies
good afternoon so we have a lot going on
this was supposed to be the big
libertarian moment in presidential
politics yeah
and we're pretty much stuck with two
guys who love to spend money well that's
true but let's not let's not declare the
libertarian moment dead after all
there's gonna be a Libertarian Party
candidate running Gary Johnson probably
love Gary Johnson if they don't screw it
up entirely the libertarian party
convention which we should not rule out
but I think Americans are going to
realize the next six months are going to
be between two guys who like government
this big or this big it's not at all
dealing with addressing the kind of
fiscal calamity that we're dealing with
as a country and are essentially the
same on a lot of issues that people care
about they'll be looking for an
alternative I think Gary Johnson has as
good a chance as anyone has as a third
party limited government guy and
generation all right but let me let me
ask you this before we move on Gary
Johnson could he be the Ross Perot of
2012 that ability well you know the
reason Rupe poll a quarterly poll
national poll found a couple weeks ago
that Ron Paul in a three-way race
between Mitt Romney Barack Obama and Ron
Paul he would pull 17 or 18 percent of
the vote
you know that's unlikely you know first
off Ron Paul is not gonna be the third
party candidate but Gary Johnson could
easily pull in the double digits if he
has a strong showing and this is where
you know when we talk about the
libertarian moment in our book the
Declaration of Independence it's not
really about who's President it's about
other forces going on and we see and the
primary challenge is that the GOP people
are bringing against people like Orrin
Hatch and Dick Lugar who between them
have 72 years worth of you know tenure
in the Senate these guys yeah you know
nobody has varicose veins like these
guys
because Nicolas we have been looking at
this all day but you know but these two
guys for the literally for the first
time in decades are having primary
challenges from Tea Party libertarian
oriented voters who are saying you know
what you guys have been around for a
long time and you just spend and spend
and spend we need to stop spending so
the libertarian moment will still can
still be upon us regardless of you know
Mitt Romney and Barack oh one of the
great disappointments with that we're
just gonna make sure you never talk
again is that is that that initiative
isn't being taken by Democrats people on
the left with issues that in which Obama
in particular but most Democrats have
been a colossal disappointment the drug
war being the the best case of that
Obama just came out with a new drug
policy I don't you guys heard this
saying basically that recommending that
every company in in the country
drug test its employees so that's going
to be a great way to have early
detection and these types well that'd be
a federal mandate or is this something
that's a strong suggestion and then
later welcome what it's going to be yeah
I don't like strong suggestions but the
next democratic politician to be primary
by a pissed-off drug reform or drug
legal as outliers will be the first as
far as I know
Democrats have got to do that if those
issues are ever going to be taken
seriously by their party what I'm
wondering is is Mitt Romney is a guy
from the private sector and that's
that's basically the main thing that
he's running on like I've run private
businesses don't you want someone from
that private world to take a heavy hand
he's also been a governor of a state
where he didn't do a lot in terms of
cutting spending he helped you know he
went along and helped develop Romney
care which was a model for Obama care
and like Obama he's really talking about
raising government spending over time
not holding it steady or cutting it and
this will be an issue because there's
still you know polls still show things
like stimulus spending tarp bailouts for
auto companies or bankers these things
are not popular and the American people
slowly but surely are understanding that
you can't keep doubling federal spending
every ten years and expect to live in an
economy I mean especially with defense
and entitlement loan yep right and
Romney is running saying that we're
we've slashed our military to the bone
and that
you know it were a dangerous
pre-nineteen 17 levels and all this
stuff he's criticizing Obama for cutting
Medicare he criticized Rick Perry for
calling Social Security a Ponzi scheme
also for cutting defense spending
defense spending hasn't been cut that's
right but what about the Buffett Rule it
was obviously voted down but it seems
like this notion of wealth equality is
going to be a big trend in the president
well you know here here is the thing
where and I think Barack Obama from a
political point of view I mean I don't
agree with him but what he's basically
saying now is look the the wealthiest
Americans the top 1% or top 2% has
gotten a lot more money over the you
know past 10 years 20 years or whatever
certainly in the recovery they should be
paying more in taxes and that actually
is a pretty simple message to sell and
it's really a tribute to his
incompetence that he's not been able to
really put that over in a clear-cut way
the problem with things like the Buffett
Rule which would make sure that
millionaires paid a certain percentage
minimum cependant yeah is that when you
start getting into the mechanics of it
it becomes very difficult and this is
one of the things where the American
people you know are often criticized for
being slow and whatnot but they're ahead
of the politicians they recognize that
this is not something that can be
implemented overnight and now if you
implement that it's not clear who
exactly it will affect and how it will
play out well let's remember what you
know that this is 2012 that we're
talking about this and Democrats had a
chance when they ran Congress and they
had the White House to end the Bush tax
cuts those were expiring they couldn't
do it they couldn't convince even with
that with a majority that they could
vote with they couldn't convince enough
of the American people to actually back
the expiration of the Bush tax cuts
which we're seeing broadly is not just
tax cuts for the rich but broadly a
middle class things that's unpopular in
America so they're they're trying to not
overcome this in terms of policy but
frame it in such a way that they can win
an election in 2012 after which I doubt
that they'll actually be able to
successfully foist any kind of these tax
gains because they're broadly unpopular
that's how we got nickel SP that
thank you and thank you